منذ الصباح الباكر والقوات الاوكرانيه
تستهدف مدينه دانيت قلب العاصمه هنا حيث
استهدفت بدايه بصواريخ فامبير تشيكيه
الصنع اطراف المدينه ومن ثم تابعت العمليه
العسكريه بالقصف المتواصل حتى وصل الى قلب
المدينه ننظر خلفي في هذا المكان هنا هذا
مركز ابحاث للعلوم في وسط المدينه استهدفت
هذا المركز سته صواريخ هايمرز الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه يعني اعترضت خمسه صواريخ
وسقط احد هذه الصواريخ الكبيره صواريخ
هايمرز خلف هذا الدمار طبعا قتيل واحد
واصابتين في هذا المركز عدا عن الاصابات
المنتشره في مواقع سقوط القذائف والصواريخ
المناطق الاخرى لان القوات الاوكرانيه
ايضا استانفت القصف على هذا المكان مره
اخرى بخمسه الطريق هاي مارس ومن ثم
استهدفت القصف بقذائف ام ترابيل سفن من
عيار امترابل سفن امريكيه الصنع التي تطلق
من مدافع هاوزر في قلب المدينه في مناطق
اخرى يعني منذ ساعتين وسكون يعم المنطقه
لكن الحقيقه ان التوتر يشمل جميع انحاء
المقاطعه او المدينه والسلطات المحليه هنا
حذرت الناس والمواطنين من الخروج الى
الشوارع خشيه استمرار العمليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بقصف المدينه طبعا احمد يصادف
اليوم السادس والعشرين من مايو هو ذكرى
انطلاق الاعمال العسكريه منذ تسع سنوات
هنا كانت اول رصاصه اطلقت قبل تسع سنوات
في مثل هذا اليوم وربما تقول يعني المصادر
هنا او المحللون والخبراء يؤكدون بان هذا
القصف يعني يعني يصادف الذكرى لانطلاق
الاعمال العسكريه التي طالبت بالانفصال عن
اوكرانيا ايضا المعارك مستعره على المناطق
الحدوديه الساخنه اقصد اطراف المدينه
الحديث عن افديف كمارنكا وصولا الى محيط
باخمط واجنحتها ووصولا الى المدن الكبرى
التي خلف باخمه حيث ان القصف الروسي وصل
الى مدينه قسطنطينه ليله امس والقوات
الروسيه التي استلمت المواقع من قوات
فاجنر التي بدات بالانسحاب يوم امس وتكمل
انسحابها حتى نهايه هذا الشهر بدات تتوسع
في محور باقي حول مدينه باقمت وتقصف مدينه
قسطنطينه في المحور الجنوبي الغربي ربما
نترك الكاميرا تسلط الضوء على اثار هذا
القصف طبعا هذا المبنى هو مركز الابحاث
العلميه ومن الناحيه الاخرى بدانا التصوير
من هناك لكن الاجهزه الامنيه منعتنا من
التصوير لان هناك مسائل سريه
منع التصوير من تلك الجانب وسمحوا لنا
بالتصوير من هذا الجانب
من حيث التكتيك المستخدم يعني في قصف
دنياسك هذه المره يعني هل اختلفت العمليه
عمليه القصف عما درجت عليه العاده في
الفتره الماضيه
القصف المتبادل مستمر منذ انطلاق العمليه
العسكريه والقوات الاوكرانيه تقصف بشكل
يومي مدينه دانيت وضواحيها كان القصف يصل
لاعداد 500 قذيفه وصاروخ بشكل يومي اليوم
24 ساعه الماضيه كان العدد حول ثلاثه مئه
300 صاروخ وقديفه لكن في فترات يعني يصبح
القصف نسبيا اقل يصل الى 100 وفي فترات
اخرى ترتفع اعداد القذائف والصواريخ لكن
القصف مستمر لكن ربما يكون على اطراف
المدينه اكثر من وسط المدينه اي يعني
استهداف
الاحياء المجاوره للعمليات العسكريه يكون
اكثر بكثير من قلب المدينه لانه ابعد
بقليل ولذلك تستخدم فقط صواريخ هايمرز
لانها طويله المدى لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات